Katie, welcome. Come to the show.
Thank you very much. This is fun.
And I liked the setup then I liked the
view, the view of Beautiful Austin,
Texas. Yeah, it's really
been fun. Actually.
This is my first south by southwest.
I know people call it south by, I want
to make it even cooler and call it sp.
Um,
but it's been really fun to be here and
it's been a really interesting for me.
So thank you for having me on the show.
Of course. I really appreciate you
making the time and I'll be honest,
I feel a little bit like that,
that Petulant Luke Skywalker and the
first star wars, everyone's like, oh,
come on when he's hanging out with Obi
wan and just missing the point because
I'm sitting here asking questions of
someone who's asked more questions of more
presidents and dignitaries than I'll
ever even have a chance to meet.
So I apologize in advance if I make any
not mistakes.
I think that if you just are curious
about people and your curiosity is genuine
and you're truly interested in someone,
uh,
I think any that that's really
what makes a good interviewer.
And so I am very happy that in state.
So I think it'll be fine.
I want to jump in to something that I
found in the course of doing my homework
that led me to a number of
different questions and I said if,
if I would ever have the chance to
ask him, I was like, wait a second.
I do have a chance to ask.
So this was something I found via NPR
and as an interview format and they were
asking you if there was any story that
made your reputation or if there was a
moment like that. And again, the Internet
sometimes misquotes things. So I'll,
you can correct if need be,
but I'll read a little bit and then
I want to ask follow up questions.
So I think I got noticed when I was doing
a tour of the White House and Barbara
Bush. I didn't think that
President Bush was there.
And suddenly I heard this cocker Spaniel
or Springer Spaniel ultimately ends up,
we arrive at Milly that smelly coming
into the room and President Bush was
following him and suddenly I had to do
an interview with the president of the
United States that I
wasn't prepared to do.
I was just getting a
tour of the White House.
So that was sort of where I found
my career path before my eyes.
But I was able to come up with enough
questions to keep them there for something
like 19 minutes and 20 seconds. So that
last sentence was the part was like, okay,
I have to ask you, if you could just
walk us through that and how on earth,
what,
do you recall any of the questions?
Do you recall how you kept the president
on the hook so to speak? Yeah. Or,
or just any recollections
from that because it's,
it's just conjure is such an
incredible image in my mind.
Well, you can imagine, you know,
when you've prepared for an interview
and something completely unexpected
happens.
So I had prepared endlessly to talk
to Barbara Bush about the White House.
It was the anniversary of the White House.
And she was giving me a tour and we
were going to be talking about Dolly
Madison's tea set and we were going
to talk about the ball and claw, uh,
legs on some of the chairs and all kinds
of things and paintings and deaths and
accoutrements that are part
and parcel of the White House.
And suddenly as you described it was like,
and I was like, Oh God,
Oh God, what's going on?
And I for some reason thought
that President Bush was
out of town or that he had
an appointment and that he
wasn't going to be around.
And it's not often that you have the
president of pop in to say hi and you have
no questions for him. So you just had it.
That was where the rubber met the road.
And I just had to pull all
these questions, you know,
pretty much out of my ass to
ask the president, you know,
the most powerful man in the free world.
So I think I asked him about Iran Contra,
I asked him about,
he was running against Bill Clinton.
So I asked him about that campaign.
I'd like to rewatch that actually to,
to see how it plays out
today and what I remember.
But I just kept on firing away.
And I remember his upper lip started
kind of quivering because I think he too
felt suddenly put on the spot.
He wasn't prepared either.
Exactly.
And we just had this very intense
kind of ratatat tat back and forth.
And finally, I remember Marlin Fitzwater
came in and I said, oh my gosh,
here's Marlon. And I think Mrs. Bush,
everyone was basically saying, okay,
that's enough.
Enough is enough.
And I remember saying to
the audience at the time,
the viewers that Marlin Fitzwater was
pulling out whatever was left of his hair
because he was pretty bald at the time.
And, uh, yeah, that was, that was,
uh, that was, uh,
a very kind of intense situation for me.
But it also showed that I could
think on my feet. Now I'm fairness.
I also had my executive producer just
sucker peppering me with questions behind
the scenes through my IFB. I
think he was nervous, yeah.
That if I had had a moment and suddenly
had nothing to say that he was going to
leave.
And of course is somebody who really
understands television and understands
audiences. He wanted to keep the
president on the hook as long as he could.
Yeah. So, uh, but it was fun.
And I remember afterwards
thinking, Oh my God. And,
and it was well received,
I think a Tom Shales who's the TV critic
for the Washington Post for a very
flattering article following that. But
that was, I think, very important because,
you know, when I did that job and
I decided I would be the co-anchor,
the today show,
it was really important for me as a female
in the business to be taken seriously
and to not be relegated to the cooking
and fashion segments. And in fact,
when I got offered the job,
I said to Michael Gardner,
the then president of NBC News,
I'll only do it if it's a 50 50 division
of labor between me and Brian Gumbel.
And I said, I, I, I had
covered the Pentagon.
I hated worked very hard and local news
and I'd gotten some very good advice
early in my career to not be typecast
as the cute girl who does features.
So,
you know,
it was important and that was
validation in a way that yes,
I could have a fun personality,
but I could really get serious
and s serious questions,
penetrating questions when I needed to,
even if I wasn't prepared.
I mean,
I,
I want to ask you about the sort of
the Chutzpah and where that comes from,
but is that a trained skill?
Is that something innate to you?
How did you end up developing that level
of aggression is too strong a word,
but that ability to capitalize
on an opportunity like that
to say, I had a lot of Moxie, which I
love that word is a good word. Yeah. And,
uh, you know, I don't know. I think
it's inherent in my personality.
I think I have been
pretty guileless if that,
if that's kind of a synonym
for moxy in a way. I mean,
I think I've always been
pretty uninhibited and very
open and very willing to go
there wherever there might be. And, uh,
I think I've always had a fair
amount of confidence in myself,
although it's wavered, you know, from
time to time through the years. But um,
yeah,
I think,
I think having super supportive parents
obviously probably fed into that. Um,
but I also think it's a little bit in
my DNA as well. A little hard word.
Yeah, I do. I actually do. And, uh,
it's sort of always fairly fearless and
not hesitant to be out front and running
for vice president when I was in fifth
grade and president of my elementary
school when I was in sixth grade and one
it always wanted to be a student leader
in that kind of thing.
Very Tracey flick from election.
Would you like a piece of gum?
Did you remember that movie?
Did you see that with Reese Witherspoon?
It's actually right.
Very, very funny movie. It kills me.
But, um, I'm not too Tracy flick ish,
but a little and um,
so,
so I think I just have
always had had the Chutzpah.
All right.
So I have you have forgotten more
interviews than I'll probably ever do,
but even in my short
stint doing a podcast,
we're just around 300 right
now. Wow. That's a lot.
It's a decent number. I mean,
I'm getting you do it every week.
I publish on average six a
month, six a month, six months.
So there, what is your
publishing schedule? Uh,
the publishing schedule
is two weeks per month.
We'll have two episodes and two per month.
We'll have a single episode.
I'm thinking of reducing that down
to once per week, but I record them.
I typically record them in batches
and then schedule them out in advance,
particularly if they're more
complex involving video.
So,
um,
do you find that sometimes they're not
topical because you don't do them around
the
publish?
Good question.
So I deliberately avoid
topical subjects and uh,
this is smart, I guess. So they can
be evergreen. That's right. And this,
there are trade offs though.
So there are people who I've
watched very closely who are in my,
let's call it peer group in the,
in the podcasting world who are very,
very good at tracking the headlines,
finding names,
inviting those people on and riding the
wave of Google juice effectively the,
the trend in traffic and search queries
to drive traffic to their podcasts.
That's very,
very effective.
But I don't want content if
I get hit by a bus tomorrow.
And I've been very,
uh,
I shouldn't say I've been unfortunate
and I think it's part of life,
but I've had a number of
very close friends and also
family members pass away in
the last,
say 12 months.
And it just reminds me that I could get
hit by a bus tomorrow and I don't want
to have put out only subject
matter that has an expiration date.
I really want it to last. So whether
it's a blog post or an interview,
I'd love for there at least,
even if there are topical components to
be themes and lessons that transcend a
certain period of time.
And that actually leads me to my question,
which is even in my relatively short
stent. Nice segue. Thank you. Thank you.
No,
it's true though because what I'm dying
to ask you is related to nervousness.
I've had a number of interviews
and episodes where I've
really been nervous for
different reasons and that has led me
to prepare in different ways and respond
in different ways.
Are there any interviews that come to
mind over your career that you were
particularly nervous about beforehand?
Yeah, I mean, I think throughout
my career, obviously dignitaries,
heads of state.
I remember I interviewed Yasser Arafat.
I was very nervous about that.
Ross Perot was very pugnacious and kind
of ornery and you never knew what he was
going to do. I think, you
know, live interviews are
really scary. Yeah, for sure.
Because you can't, you
know, edit things out.
You can't ask a question over again in
a more eloquent way and you're really on
the spot. So I think live
interviews would make me nervous.
I remember I was supposed to interview
with Tom Brokaw. Dot. Oj Simpson,
uh,
after he was acquitted and I was a
nervous wreck at the very thought of it
because I thought, first of
all, I'm not a prosecutor.
I,
my husband who had passed away later,
but who was alive covering a lot
of the Oj trial, knew everything.
He was a criminal defense, white
collar, criminal defense lawyer.
And I just remember thinking that
this is just a no win situation.
First of all,
I can't retry the case,
nor could I cause I don't really have
the talent or the skills to do that.
And secondly,
it was so divisive and
polarizing that whole situation.
And so racially charged and I at the
time and still do to a certain extent,
just hated like people attacking me.
And I thought it was just a no
win situation. So when he bailed,
I wanted to do a happy dance.
I was so excited. So, you know,
situations like that would
make me extremely nervous
when I saw so much risk and
so much downside and very
little upside. Right. Um, but,
but I think whenever I'm
interviewing people who are
really smart and really knowledgeable
about a certain area and I don't know
nearly as much as they do,
that can be a hard,
and I think also when you're interviewing
somebody about a wide range of public
policy and you're not,
you're not necessarily a policy wonk,
that's challenging too,
but you know,
to go to the White House and interview
a president either live or even on tape
is really stressful.
Interviewing Sarah Palin
when I interviewed her
because I thought it was so
important to strike the right tone,
asked the right questions and, uh,
it was a very critical time,
I think to understand her motivations
and actually her abilities.
So, um, I still get nervous
when I have big interviews.
In the case of, let's take Pailin as an
example. How did you prepare for that?
Can you walk us through some of
your preparation? Well, I think, um,
I worked with my friend Brian
Goldsmith with whom I do a podcast.
He sort of my partner in crime
on the podcast. He's a very,
very smart person who really follows
politics and public policy very closely.
And we worked together at CVS and when
I found out she was going to do the
interview,
we just immediately started to read
everything we possibly could about her,
about Alaska, about um, you know,
everything that was Germane to that,
the presidential campaign,
what was going on in the country.
I called Madeline Albright, I called
Sam Nunn. I called Richard Haas,
who's the head of the council on foreign
relations. I called people and I said,
Hey,
I'm interviewing governor Palin.
Of course everyone knew was in tune
with what was going on in the campaign.
And I'd say to them,
what do you think are some of the areas
that you think are really important that
the American people need to know
about and hear her perspective on?
Um,
so I would ask people,
I think I asked a few other
correspondence about it. Um,
read a lot and you know,
you also have to make some very difficult
choices because as you know, you know,
they're probably a lot more
questions than you have time for it.
Then your guest has time for.
So then we'd had had to
winnow them down and um,
but it was also really
important for me to,
uh, you know, make sure my tone was right,
that my approach was right.
That I,
I remember going in and saying I would
have an almost parkinsonian effect with
very little facial expressions.
I didn't want people to misinterpret that.
I was looking at her like,
what are askance? And uh,
and, and Madeleine Albright offered me, I
think the best piece of advice, she said,
just let her talk.
And I think so often in conversations,
I don't know if you find this true in
a podcast because it may be different
since things can be edited,
but you try to fill the empty spaces
and people feel very uncomfortable with
silence.
And I know I do because I want to make
sure that I keep the conversation going.
And then of course, in live television
you can't have these, you know,
that dead air.
But I,
I really took that advice to
heart and I wouldn't jump in.
I wouldn't jump into rescue her if
she was giving a convoluted answer.
I wouldn't jump in if she felt awkward.
I wouldn't jump in if she paused.
I just let her talk and didn't.
And I really resisted that temptation,
which I have because I'm a pleaser
and I want to make sure people feel
comfortable.
Um,
so we spent probably three solid days
preparing for that interview and I really
wanted to ask questions that required
accumulated knowledge and critical
thinking. So I wanted to talk
about big issues and you know,
honestly I look at some of
those questions and I'd say,
I don't know how I would answer that,
but I'm also not a public policy expert.
Um, but I tried to ask questions
that weren't Gotcha questions,
even though she insisted they were,
but that people deserve to know a how
much she knew about any given subject and
how she would approach it
and what her thinking was.
And what became abundantly clear is
she just wasn't ready to be put in this
position.
She wasn't ready for prime time and
it had nothing to do with her gender.
I just think her experience and her
perhaps lack of intellectual curiosity,
did not equip her to do an interview about
substantive issues facing the country
or the world.
Let her talk.
I really loved that. I
got, I've had the chance to
become friends with someone in cal Fussman
who was one of the senior writers who
worked on the,
what I learned column for Esquire for
decades and is interviewed million
different people.
And I asked him for feedback when I was
starting the podcast to read some of the
transcripts and to see if he saw
opportunities for improvement.
And he said such a nice guy, real
sweetheart of a guy, and he said,
let the silence do the work.
Because I was trying to rescue people.
If I asked a question and it started
meandering or something like that,
I would jump in and he goes,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You need to give them more space and
give them time to follow up or to add to
their answer. But it's, I think it's very
unnatural. Even if you're not a pleaser,
as a human being in
conversation, it's, it's,
it's unnatural to leave a lot of space.
But as an interviewer,
it's really, it seems
really, really useful. Uh,
you mentioned a Ross Perot
and him being pugnacious.
Is there a toolkit or a more effective
way to respond to someone in an interview
if they are ordinary or a pugnacious?
Okay.
Um, I don't know. I think,
I think it depends on the situation.
Uh, I remember he was like, Katie,
Katie,
you know,
sort of admonishing me like I was
misbehaving fifth grader or something. Um,
but I think, uh, you know,
that's a hard, I don't know.
I think you just have to kind of stand
your ground and not be intimidated.
I think people like that want
you to back down or want you,
want to make you uncomfortable and,
and,
and make you ill at ease
and catch you off guard.
So I think you just have to really work
at maintaining your composure and not be
thrown by it.
And that's very hard on national
television to not be thrown by someone,
kind of scolding you.
Right.
What's, you mentioned, the
facial expressions and so on,
which is something I haven't
even considered because
this is my very first few
experiments in video, so I'm
not now I'm like, oh my God,
what have been doing with
my face? But, uh, if you're
being scolded on national TV,
it's not just what you say, it's also how
you respond. Right. Of course. Of course.
So you really have to have trained a
poker face or at least some awareness.
Self awareness. Yeah. Through the
profession. That seems really hard.
I would definitely get fired
if my thought bubbles right.
Perfect. Came public,
that's for damn sure.
But on the flip side,
are there any interviews that he that
come to mind? You've had so many, uh,
but where after you're done,
you just in the moments of finishing
the interview, thank yourself God,
I hope the equipment was working.
Like I really hope we caught
that because it was so good.
Are there any that come to mind
where like, oh wow, that was really,
that's one that I'm really proud of.
Yeah,
I a lot.
Uh,
I think one that's sort of,
that I usually dust off when I'm asked
this question is one I did after the
massacre it at Columbine
high school and it was four,
maybe 4:00 AM Colorado time is
how many hours behind New York,
two or three, three, two.
So it was 5:00 AM and
it was April and yet,
and so this guy was pitch
black but it was snowing.
So it was this very dramatic,
dramatic scene.
And I interviewed Michael Shoals who had
lost his son, Isaiah and Craig Scott,
who had lost his sister Rachel
and they were so broken,
understandably broken,
shattered, not even broken.
They were shattered and it
had happened the day before
and they came on the today show,
which I think is always
such an interesting thing.
Why do people in this grief stricken
state come to talk about their loved ones?
I've always been fascinated by that and
thought it would be a really excellent
thesis for a psychology student
about grief and sort of the public
acknowledgement of grief.
And Anyway,
they came and uh,
and it was just a heartbreaking interview.
And to witness them kind of
looking to each other for comfort.
Michael shoals was a big burly black
guy and Craig Scott was this sort of
angelic toe headed teenager.
And I've actually stayed in touch
with Craig Scott and they held hands,
uh, during the interview. And
it was just, it was sort of the,
the personification of loss and
sorrow and these two people and
just holding onto each other for
dear life. It was really profound.
It was really, I was
witnessing it less. Uh,
I was Whitney's,
I was witnessing it more than
interviewing them, you know,
because they were in this particular
space and I was an observer really.
So I always think about that interview
as being after it was over a really
important interview for people to watch.
And I hope I handled it in a sensitive,
thoughtful way that both
respected them as human beings,
but also guided them so they
could express themselves,
you know, are situations where
you just really want people too.
You really want to help
them get through it.
I mean there are all kinds
of situations I'm sure,
and all the interviews you've done,
there's some cases where you know,
you want to afflict the comfortable and
there are other cases when you want to
come to comfort the afflicted.
And that was definitely the latter.
And so, uh, just helping
them through it. And, uh,
that was a really,
I don't want to say special,
but significant experience
for me as a person.
So I want to, I want to explore
this. I'm writing down that one.
There times when you want to afflict
the comfortable tells me we're going to
cover that.
Say is the journalist's job.
I've never heard that before. No,
no, that's really useful. Heuristic,
uh, want to talk about
grief a bit? So I've,
uh,
I've lost a number of,
like I mentioned close friends and a
mentor in the last 12 months. And uh,
you mentioned your husband, uh,
who passed away earlier. Uh,
and if I get any facts wrong,
obviously please correct me.
But colorectal cancer 42 40,
which really caught my attention.
And My,
the first time I had an opportunity to
go abroad outside of the United States
was to Japan as an exchange student.
And I lived with a family,
went to Japanese high school and I'm
still close to that family 25 years later.
And the father and that host family
is my second father effectively.
And I plan on bringing my American family
to Japan later this year to meet them
for the first time,
my two families.
And I just found out that my host
father is in the hospital, uh,
late stage,
very aggressive cancer diagnosed,
uh, as metastasized, probably will
pass away in the next two months.
And what kind of cancer? Uh, it's,
I would have to go back to
the email because it was,
it was very emotional and then cognitively
difficult for me to translate because
there's a lot, it's in Japanese and it
was all specialized medical terminology,
but it's, it's in the lung, it's in
the liver. Uh, a lifelong smoker,
very typical for Japanese of that age.
I think it might be also a soft gel,
but um,
and it's, uh, I know that it has,
it's now also in the lymph nodes,
so he's intubated in the hospital
and only the mother and the,
the brothers can come visit.
Uh,
so this is ha has had me
thinking about grief and uh,
is there anything I should do
in advance to prepare for that?
And they'd just be very curious if you're
willing to talk about it to describe
your experience of grieving and you
could start at any point in time,
but as it relates to your experience with,
with your husband and certainly after
that we can get into it. But I mean,
you've done a tremendous job of,
of highlighting the types of diagnostic
tools and preventative tools that people
can use, which we'll talk about. But
okay.
I don't even know how to
think about grief. I mean,
I don't know if I've allowed myself
to ever experience it before,
but I know I'm going to be hit
with a hammer. I thought though,
you had a couple of friends that I
did. No, I did. They have passed away.
And it's been very recent that it hasn't
been this close. These are friends,
but they're not a second father to
me. Uh, and I think in a sense the,
um, the mentor passed away.
It did hit me pretty hard,
but if the only in the last six to 12
months actually been allowing myself to
feel more things, that's a
much longer story. But, uh,
have a kind of a conflicted
relationship with this person.
I know I've had a lot of armor for
decades that have built up over time for a
lot of different reasons and,
um,
it's been very useful for
some things for protecting me,
but I've realized that it also keeps a
lot in that is very ultimately corrosive.
So I'm trying to develop
more of an ability to feel
and instead of looking at it
as a liability,
um,
slash I don't know. How do you,
how do you describe grief? Um,
okay.
I mean, I, I can talk a little bit about
my personal experience. You know, I had a,
I was on top of the world,
had this great job,
had two beautiful children,
and of course a wonderful husband.
Uh,
I have to say we were having challenges,
some challenges in our marriage because
I think I had this just sort of out of
the blue success and some suddenly
became a household name and had all this
attention,
which I think can put a lot of pressure
on a relationship or suddenly it doesn't
feel the power dynamic doesn't
feel as equal. Right. Um,
but, uh, you know, we were,
we were really, you know,
and love and enjoying our lives and,
uh, you know, just out of the
blue, Jay hadn't been feeling well.
He had been tired. He'd been traveling
and we kept thinking, oh, east,
we have two little kids. He's
covering the Oj Simpson trial. He was,
uh, you know, his schedule was crazy.
And then out of the blue he just was
doubled over in pain. And our nanny,
who was Irish at the time called and said,
Jay's doubled over in pain and,
uh,
I don't know what to do.
So he didn't have a doctor like
so many young men, which is,
you know, if anybody
takes, there are many,
I think takeaways from our conversation,
I hope.
But one is that men especially,
I think because women go
see gynecologists honestly,
that a lot of men don't go
and get physicals or they
don't even have a GP or an
internist.
And Shay was one of those guys who played
Lacrosse and football and in college
and was never smoked ever. I know
that he ever even tried a cigarette.
I never,
I don't think he even tried pot ever.
It's sort of crazy when you think
about it. Drank moderately, uh,
took pretty good care of
himself. I mean, and uh,
and it just boom,
he had stage four metastatic colon cancer.
So we went from one day,
just everything was great.
We were buying a house in the country and,
or had a house in the country
and we're really enjoying that.
And Jay was riding horses in central
park and doing his thing professionally.
And I was at the today show and our
girls were great. And, uh, we had,
I mean,
Carrie was less than a year at the time
or just had turned a year old when he
was diagnosed on April 3rd,
1998, 1997. Sorry,
he died nine months later in January.
But,
um, you know, it's just, it's so,
it's so debilitating and shattering
and destabilizing and you know,
it's such a process and I was in such
denial and he was one of these very smart
people, but he didn't want
to know about his health.
He didn't want to know the gory details.
I don't know why,
because he was so smart,
intellectually curious and
interested and I don't know,
maybe he knew. So I kept all this
stuff from him, which I really regret.
I would say, oh, there's only
shadows on your liver. Don't worry.
It's going to be okay. Uh,
we're going to figure it out.
I remember sending his scans to Nih,
you know,
cause I had a lot of
connections because of my job.
And I remember very prominent cancer
scientists calling me and saying,
Oh God, this is, this is really bad. He,
I arranged for him to get
a hepatic artery pump,
which pushed the chemo directly to
his liver that was covered. I mean,
the tumor burden on his liver was
awful. And, uh, anyway,
so I was, I went into,
I think my,
my husband John says I'm very
good in an emergency. You know,
I get very focused and very
proactive and driven and I went into,
I am going to try to fix this mode.
And uh,
so I was sort of doing that I think
to avoid the grief because I had to do
something and it was just,
I mean, what can I say?
It's the worst thing in the world
to see someone, first of all,
your life just changed in an instant then
to see someone's suffering then to try
to figure out how can you help
somebody. I mean, it's just,
it's really overwhelming and uh,
you know,
I think grieving process began the day
he was diagnosed because my doctor,
who was the internist, Jay went to see
when he was in this pain. You know,
he pulled me aside and to one of those
little patient rooms in the hospital and
said, it's, it's the, this is really bad,
that the prognosis is very bleak.
So what do you do with that?
Except for do everything you
possibly can to change the outcome,
which you realize you probably
can't change anyway. It's a very,
uh, challenging thing to
deal with, but you know, I,
maybe my regrets will help you
with your situation and that
I never really said to Jay,
what are your hopes and
dreams for your kids?
Can you write the girls a letter?
Can we videotape you talking to them?
Uh,
to say everything I wanted to say to
him because that was an acknowledgement
that he was going to die
and I just couldn't do that.
So maybe if things are so bleak for
this person is so special to you,
first of all, you need to tell
him no and you need to write him.
Maybe go see him and feel that,
that you don't have any regrets.
Thank you.
Okay.
So the only segue I can possibly
think of from that is very close to,
yeah,
they can always go what I used to do
on the today show, on a lighter note,
I mean I suppose on a lighter
note, although it's, it's a,
it's a shade of the same color.
Uh, so there's, there's a very
interestingly titled Paper in an
Academic Journal and the title is quote,
the impact of a celebrity promotional
campaign on the use of coal, uh,
colon cancer screening,
the Katie Kirk effect.
And it goes on to detail the increase in
the number of colonoscopies because of
your awareness campaign or campaigns.
Uh, so, and I was looking at this,
I've read a lot of
studies and the p values,
so the likelihood that it could be
attributed to chance is really, really,
really low. I mean it's, the data are
really compelling. Looking at this,
can you, can you tell us the
story of how it happened?
Well, that's a university of
Michigan study. I think that paper,
and I think it was in the annals
of internal medicine possibly,
which I think in this case
should be called the angels.
But I basically really wanted to educate
people because I didn't understand
colon cancer. I didn't, I'd
never really heard of it.
I guess I had vaguely when President
Reagan had a polyp and I thought,
Gee, I have this opportunity. I
have this bully pulpit pulpit.
I have a platform to educate
people. So, um, again,
Jeff Sucker,
who at the time was my executive producer,
he ironically had also been diagnosed
with colon cancer in his thirties.
And so he was a very receptive
audience for my idea. And I said,
can I get a colonoscopy on television?
I don't, I'm too young to get one.
You know,
was wasn't 50 yet.
I was only 41 when my husband died.
But I said,
we need to demystify this procedure.
So that was my thinking
to just educate people.
And um,
and it was sort of,
this was before people were doing
things like this and talking about it,
but it just seemed a
perfectly logical thing to do.
And I think it was very helpful for me
in a situation where I felt so powerless
and I don't know about you,
but that's the worst feeling in the world
world to feel powerless feeling. No.
And so here was an opportunity for me to
use whatever power I did have to maybe
help other people and
possibly even save some lives.
So that was really the
thinking. And uh, you know,
that that's sort of started me on a
journey to be a cancer advocate for all
kinds of cancer and to continue
emphasizing the importance of screening.
I'm taking a very well known person to
get his first colonoscopy next week.
And um,
you know,
I really appreciate people's willingness
to talk about this and just spread the
word.
And because it's so preventable,
it has a 92% cure rate if it's detected
early and it's the second leading cancer
killer of men and women combined.
So I feel like, you know,
that will probably be the
first line in my obituary.
I hope it won't be journalists,
but it will be sort of
cancer advocate and uh,
and it's something I'm really
proud of that I was willing to do.
Well, I would say even at this point,
it could be the first line in this, in,
in certainly a number of
measurable senses, right?
So your cofounder of Standup to cancer
and that has raised more than 500 million
at this point to fund scientific
research team. That's a lot of money.
That's a big chunk of change.
There's a big chunk of change. Yeah.
And that's what started by
nine women who together, um,
we're frustrated with the
pace of cancer research.
I think standup has really changed the
paradigm of how cancer research is done.
It's really emphasizing collaboration
rather than competition getting these
institutions and you know,
pharmaceutical companies and biotech
firms to actually talk to each other,
to pull their re pull pool,
their resources and,
and their brain power really.
And it's since been adapted by
people like Sean Parker, Joe Biden,
when it comes to the way
they're approaching cancer.
So it's been a phenomenal thing.
I'm so proud of these women.
So proud of these scientists.
Cause at first they weren't
too jiggy about collaborating.
Well that's what,
that's a really complex potentially
complex problem to solve.
Right?
It's worked better than others. Yeah.
Quite candidly. But uh, you know,
we've been able to get three drugs
approved by the FTA and a lot of promising
research done because the scientists
are willing to work together and it just
makes all the sense in the
world. But it does, it's against,
are kind of very primal impulses to,
you know,
be credit mon green and not want to
share the spotlight with people. So it's,
it, it, at times it's been challenging,
but now that it's been great. Yeah.
What are the ingredients or the strategies
that your team is used to encourage
these people who have not previously
collaborated to collaborate? Yeah,
I don't know. You know, I
think their shoe, it's, I,
I don't give the organization any credits.
Their sheer decency and their,
their desire to really help patients and
to come up with better treatments for
so many people who have suffered from
this disease and lost the battle.
So I think that, you know, it
was just different, you know,
people don't like change as you know.
Yeah.
And it was just a different way
of doing things. And as I said,
I think in some cases maybe it hasn't
been as successful as it could have been.
In other cases it's just
been amazingly successful.
So you know, these are the real heroes,
by the way, these cancer scientists,
first of all,
they are ridiculously intelligent,
brilliant people.
And you know,
these are the people who should be on the
cover of celebrity magazines and they,
we should be doing award
ceremonies for them.
They sh they should be the
real rock stars of our culture.
Unfortunately they don't
get much attention. They
don't get that much funding.
They just don't get what they
deserve as far as I'm concerned.
So they're amazing.
And that's been another really
gratifying part of this work is to get,
get to getting to know the scientists who
are so selfless and so hardworking and
so dedicated to helping people.
I'd love to ask you about how you choose
projects because we just discussed as a
c it seems like a very
natural consequences of your
personal experience and then
capitalizing on the platform
and the assets that you have.
So it was a very natural fit.
I can only imagine that you get hundreds
and thousands of proposals that I'm
sure other people help that with basic
criteria, but I don't really don't.
So how do you select,
you must have so much inbound and
certainly throughout your career I would
imagine.
I don't know.
I mean I don't really, I've
worked for companies, you know,
I uh, in local news and jumped around,
which you sort of had, you know,
at the time you kind of had to do to get
experience and become confident and you
know,
reporting and doing on air work.
And then I worked at companies
like NBC for 15 maybe 20 years,
if you count my time covering the
Pentagon and working in local news.
So probably 20 years,
then went to CBS for five.
Then I did a talk show for two
that I worked at Yahoo for four.
So I've really worked for big companies
servicing them and doing what I needed
to do to hopefully contribute to what,
you know,
their general mission was. And, um,
and now I'm sort of, I don't know,
I'm just kind of at a weird place.
I do things that I believe will have
impact that give me creative freedom.
Uh, sometimes I miss working for companies
because I love working with people.
I'm a super sociable person and I like,
I really get energy from other
people and the atmosphere I'm in.
Um, but now I, I'm just
trying to figure it out.
And it's hard because the landscape
is so fragmented and there are so few
communal experiences. When I did the
today show, I sort of felt like, oh,
not everybody. I didn't, I wasn't
that egotistical, but I thought, oh,
a lot of people are kind of watching this.
And it felt kind of like a community.
And now, I mean, a lot of people
still watch the today show,
but it just seems there's so many options
and so many things to do with our time
and this attention economy that,
um,
Tristan Harris talks about.
Do you know Tristan Harris?
Yeah, I know of him. I had stopped him.
You would love him. Fascinating guy.
33 years old. He's an
amazing person. I let,
I interviewed him for my nat
Geo series, but um, you know,
uh,
so I just tried to do things that I'm
going to enjoy that I think will somehow
contribute to the conversation
and that will get some attention.
But that's hard,
you know?
So I think right now you just have to
do things you really enjoy and like,
you know,
devoting your time to,
what do you do it in your
time to right now? And I'm,
I'm thinking maybe that's the leading
question or am I, I'm suppose,
I suppose what I'm hoping to explore
a little bit is a America inside out.
And if you could tell us what that
is and why you chose to do it.
Well,
I decided to leave Yahoo when
it was bought by Verizon.
No hurt feelings. I just, it was
never really the right fit for me.
And I've, I've talked about that a little
bit with Kara Swisher. He pressure,
you know, Kara, Kara on the podcast.
Yeah, she's great. I really like Cara.
I just like her, no bs, very no bs. Yeah.
And I, but I also think
she's a very kind person. Um,
probably not everyone who she's written
about feels the same way. But, um,
I wanted to,
uh,
I wanted to explore some of these
issues that I thought were not getting
attention.
Biz Stone in this book I wrote
about advice said if you see a need,
fill it,
you know,
in terms of what to do with your life
or if you're entrepreneurial or if you
want to,
if you want to be of service to people.
And I think basically, don't we all want
our book, our work to matter? I think,
I don't think making money is
the be all end all for people.
Maybe it's easy to say that once
you've made some money, but, um,
I wanted to explore these topics that I
thought were getting short shrift in the
media, that, that everything
is so ephemeral now.
You can't even remember partially because
there's so much happening at once.
You can't remember what Donald Trump
did two days ago or you can't remember.
I mean, it's so much.
It's TMI, isn't it? Yeah.
And I think you see,
you can't even digest it and
think about it and contemplate it.
And I felt like everything's
happening so fast.
Can we think about things a little more?
And what are some of the things that
I believe we should be thinking about?
And it was, they were things that
were happening before our eyes,
but we weren't really giving
them any considerations.
So I had done a documentary for National
Geographic called gender revolution
about our changing notions of gender and
how were people are not really binary
as much as they used to be with
very specific male, female, blue,
pink, you know, traits. And you
grow up and you're this way. Um,
and now I,
this whole notion of gender fluidity
and kind of being nonbinary and all this
stuff was really,
they were relatively new concepts for me.
And I had whiffed on an interview
I did with Laverne Cox and uh,
Carmen Carrera and less with Laverne.
But with Carmen when I asked her, uh,
an inappropriate question
about her genitals,
basically her private parts and I taped
the interview and at the time I thought
she was quite offended and
told me why. And I said, I'm,
when the producers asked,
I said,
keep that in because I want people
to understand why that's an offensive
question if you don't mind me asking.
What was the question? I said,
what's the situation with
your private parts, you know,
about gender reassignment surgery?
And it just grossly inappropriate.
But I didn't really that and I was
trying to do, believe it or not,
a public service by at least talking about
transgender individuals and trying to
help people understand it.
So my motives were actually pure,
but my question was really clumsy and
I kept it in the show and it got just,
I remember I was on a plane going to ces
and it was my birthday and I looked on
Twitter.
Oh my God,
I'm surprised there wasn't smoke coming
out of my phone because it was just
merciless.
I need the scathing criticism I got.
And I of course regretted
that I kept it in,
but I kept it in for the right
reasons too. But I ended up,
long story short, sorry, I'm going on
and on about this, but I ended up saying,
you know, I want to learn.
I want to understand. I felt
bad. I also felt, you know,
defensive and upset.
But ultimately I said,
I need to educate myself and I need
to help other people understand this
community.
So I did a documentary
called Gender Revolution for
National Geographic and they
were quite pleased with it and I was
happy that I was able to do it and I
learned a lot. So then they
came back to me and they said,
would you like to do some war?
So I didn't have a job at the time.
Um,
and I thought,
and I think this is sort
of the new way of working,
you don't necessarily work
for one company, right?
You do it more project by project.
Um,
and I really done so pretty much every
job and network news at this point in
time. So I said sure, I'd love to.
And I came up with six topics that I
thought deserved a little more analysis or
exploration and that's the series and
it's really been interesting and really,
really exhausting. What are some
of the topics? So I'm doing,
the first one is called rewriting history,
but I'm spelling it R, I, g, h, t, I,
n,
g.
And it's really about our memorial
landscape and confederate iconography,
statues,
monuments that led me to Charlottesville
right before and during that quote
unquote outright rally. That by the
way, is not Charlottesville, Virginia.
People have now associated this kind of
bigotry and disgusting white supremacy
as being relating to Charlottesville.
It has nothing to do with Charlottesville.
They picture let's fill because I
think it's a progressive town. And um,
so it's,
it's really on how these
confederate statues are dividing us,
that they're so important for some
southerners who see it as celebrating
southern heritage and so offensive to
black Americans who feel they are a real
poke in the eye and supporting people
who wanted to perpetuate the institution
of slavery.
So I just wanted to peep,
I wanted to hear more about that
where the controversy started in
Charlottesville.
It was started by a 16 year old African
American high school student who started
a petition and I went to see
Mitch Landrieu in New Orleans.
I talked to Julianne Moore who did a
petition to change the name of her high
school in Northern Virginia.
And then I went and talked to Brian
Stevenson of the equal justice initiative,
who is just one of my personal
heroes about his project,
which he's doing.
You would love him and lynching project
where he is collected soil from the
lynching sites from 4,400 lynching sites
throughout the south because that's a
chapter of our history. Those literally
been buried and well not literally,
but yes,
literally and figuratively and buried.
And he has taken the soil with the help
of descendants of people who've been
lynched and put the soil in Mason jars
with the name of the lynching victim on
the jar.
And he has a home memorial that
he's opening in Montgomery in April.
He's a very deeply thoughtful person,
does a lot of work with mass incarceration
and with sort of the long tail of
slavery and how it's affected race and
African Americans in this country long
past the civil war. So anyway,
that's kind of like, I mean we're,
can you really watch something
like that on television
and you see is the what,
what would be success for you?
Not In terms of views or
anything like that, but the,
the impact of an episode
that on say a viewer, is it,
is it that they changed their mind?
Is it that they see it,
they view an issue that before was just
a sound bite or two headlines and they
see the shades of gray in something
that was actually very nuanced.
What do you hope it will do?
Number two would be really
good at deeper understanding.
Uh, a, a, uh,
I guess remembering what it feels like
to have empathy for some of these point
of view, to um, have more context,
to be able to talk about
it in a more educated,
intelligent way to, I
don't know, you just,
there's so much surface stuff you don't
really know what's underneath what lies
beneath the story.
And oftentimes I think if
you do a little digging,
then you just have,
you just understand it more
and you can talk about it and,
and a less kneejerk way in a more nuanced,
less emotional, empathetic,
empathetic way. You know,
these statues for a lot
of people are deeply,
deeply offensive and I don't think
they belong in public squares,
in public spaces, which are
very important, you know,
in terms of setting the
tone for a community.
That's why urban planners spend a lot
of time thinking about these things and
uh,
it's,
it's just thought provoking and I don't
think we think about these things enough
or have an opportunity to really
talk about them. So that's just one.
I'm doing one on what it's like to
be a Muslim in America right now.
Because there's so many prejudices
and misconceptions about Islam,
about Muslims,
and 50% of Americans say
they'd never met a Muslim.
And so I'm trying to introduce
some of them to those people,
to Muslims virtually. And
um, you know, I don't know.
I'm trying to just foster some kind of
deeper understanding and connection for
people with things that may
seem foreign to them with,
with things that they may feel strongly
about but don't necessarily know why.
Maybe it's because their friends do.
Yeah. Maybe their beliefs aren't
actually their beliefs at all.
The beliefs of their parents or their
coworkers or whatever it is that they've
absorbed. Yeah. They didn't
worry about it through thought.
They write farm fed
from their, from their news feeds. Sure.
Through likeminded people who share
their beliefs. And I don't know,
it's, it's kind of ambitious to
even want to do that. And you know,
I just have to keep trying
because that's what I enjoy doing.
And I do think that I possibly could
be a helpful conduit for people.
A proxy for the average Joe or chose the
dean who is curious about the world and
wants to understand it better and wants
to meet people and talk to people and
see if they can, I don't know,
trying to make sense of it all.
I Dunno,
does that, I think that's
it. I think that's a very
noble objective. I know that.
I think, I think if you aim for that, even
if you partially fail, you will still,
you will still create a lot of positive
change, right. Since I could be, I mean,
that would be certainly what
I would tell myself that a
try.
And I do think this younger
generation is much more receptive to,
you know, trying to change the
world in a good way. You know,
you see those kids in Parkland,
Florida and it's just so moving.
And so, um, you know, I'm hoping,
I'm hoping that it will,
it'll maybe, I don't know,
get people to talk to their friends
about it and maybe counter some of this
stuff that they're seeing
and say, actually, you know,
white extremists have committed three
times the violent acts that Muslim
extremists have committed since
nine 11 or in the last 15 years.
But the media coverage leaves you with
the perception that's not the case. Right?
And so we can all kind of just be more
aware and more critical and not in a
negative way,
but critical thinkers about the
kind of information that's incoming.
I know we only have a few minutes left.
If you had a billboard,
metaphorically speaking, and you
could put a word, a phrase, a quote,
any type of message or question to get
out to millions or billions of people,
what might you put on that billboard?
I'm watching three billboards right now.
All I can think of is the billboards that,
uh,
Frances McDormand put up. Um, uh,
you know, there's so many important
things, right? I guess I would say, uh,
something about voting, you know, if
you don't vote, you can't complain.
Okay.
There are ways to vote too. I
mean, I understand the literal.
Yeah. I mean, I think for me it's
actually the elections, right?
Because I think it's what
55% of Americans voted.
It was the worst turnout in it
since I think 1994 or something.
And, and I just don't understand
how people can be that apathetic.
They have to care about the country and
they have to educate themselves about
the issues. And I just, uh,
it's just infuriating to me
that people don't vote. And so,
especially in the
midterms and they need to,
they need to really hold our politicians
accountable and if they want to,
you know,
be the change they wish to see or
whatever they need to get involved in the
political process.
So I think that's what I would do.
I get infuriated me if people didn't vote
in the last election or they threw it
the way their vote by voting for someone,
that just would never be
a of chance. Right, right.
And I felt like saying to them,
that's a vote for the other person.
If you're comfortable with that,
you, you know, just so you know,
that's helping elect someone,
you may not want to be precedent.
And so I just, I just hope people take
that really, really seriously. And I,
I don't know, I just hope they vote
for people for the right reasons too.
Yeah. And the focus on action
instead of complaining,
I think that you can simulate,
you can create the illusion of action by
jumping on social media and complaining,
but,
or they call that slacktivism right?
Yeah.
Slacktivism yeah.
You need to actually get up off
your ass and make things happen.
And part of that is
engaging in ways like that.
Yeah. Um, but that's, I think,
what would you put on a billboard?
Damn. Flying Question. I
would say I might put up, uh,
I've thought about this of course.
Cause I asked this question a fair amount.
I would, I would put up, uh, I'll give,
I'll give two answers. I'm going to cheat.
But the one that I usually say is you
are the average of the five people you
associate with most. So psychologically,
emotionally, politically,
physically,
you are going to be the average of the
handful of people you spend the most time
with. So pick those people very, very,
very carefully. Um, and the, the other,
I'm actually stealing from Bj Miller,
who's a hospice care physician,
also triple amputee.
He was a warning story when I attended
Princeton because a few years before he
had been climbing on this commuter train
called the dinky and it was wearing a
big watch and electricity art and
burned off three of his limbs.
And he since became at
Princeton and he sent,
he as well after that point became an MD,
has helped a thousand plus people to
die with terminal diagnoses in something
called the Zen hospice
center. But he, he's,
he's since expanded beyond that San
Francisco and they have a very uncommon
approach to death and,
and shepherding people from a terminal
diagnosis to ultimately passing.
And they do it in a really
beautiful way, uh, that,
that I think lens piece to
a lot of people. And when
I asked him this question,
he also, in turn, he said,
got it from a bumper stickers.
Who knows who ultimately said this, but
he said, I would put on a billboard,
don't believe everything that you think.
And I thought that was really
profound to contemplate.
That's good for my series. Yeah. Don't
believe everything that you think.
So I revisit that a lot myself. And that
can be your beliefs about other people,
but also your beliefs about yourself,
the stories,
the narratives that you escape to that
ultimately don't serve you, don't.
Sounds like a remarkable person. Has He
gotten a lot of attention? Not Enough.
Not enough attention. He, he,
he's an English readily think
this is an APP person. I should,
you would love this. You would love
him. He's, he's incredible. And
he does, he has, he has
procecies or prosthetics and,
and he, he sees these cities,
whatever it is, he has those.
And we actually talked to the podcast
at some point. He mentioned in passing,
it's like, well, the other week
when I was riding my motorcycle,
and then he kept going and I said, wait,
hold on. You're missing three limbs,
you have a motorcycle.
And he told me about this process he
went through with the help of many people
to custom modify a motorcycle.
He,
he wanted to be on a motorcycle to feel
the wind in his face and he rides a
motorcycle.
He's a fascinating guy and hilarious.
Bj Miller as I married. Uh,
I don't think so, but I'm,
I'm unsure. Yeah. You met him when
he spoke at Princeton. No worries.
I heard about him.
I saw him initially in the,
I believe it was the Princeton
Alumni weekly, the alumni magazine,
and I tore out that page and I said one
day I'm going to track this guy down.
I put it into a scrapbook. And that
was before I ever started the podcast.
And then at one point,
I don't know how it happened exactly.
It might've been an email
from someone else who said,
do you know who it was an email from
someone else has from a scientist at UCF?
He said, well, Duh, Duh,
Dah, something something. Bj
Miller. I said, wait a second.
That rings a bell. Google search on my
God. That's that guy. Years ago I said,
someday I'm going to meet. And
I said, I'll do one better.
I want to interview him.
And that's how it came to.
And so did have you become friends?
I would say we're definitely
on friendly terms.
I still haven't met him in person.
Oh my gosh.
Well you have
and um, he's a, he's an
incredible, incredible man.
You should do your podcast,
you know,
like on location sometimes
I would say it really does,
uh,
Linda different feel to the podcast.
You could go to his, actually,
it would be incredible.
You should go to his hospice.
Yeah.
And you should talk to some
of his patients that would
be so profound and then
put together.
I'm talking to your producers over there.
I put together something that would
be really beautiful because people,
myself included really don't,
don't still don't know how
to talk about death. Yeah.
They are terrified of it. I am. Yeah. Uh,
and uh,
I think that you would be doing such a
public service to help help people kind
of get a different perspective
on dying if that's possible.
If my own thinking about the subject is
any indication based on conversations
with people like Bj and based on,
okay.
Speaking with someone like you
and asking you about grief.
This is why I'm asking because I don't,
I don't yet feel like I have a complete
toolkit for even thinking about it.
You should also read Sheryl
Sandberg's book option B. Yeah.
Which I thought was really brave
of her to write with Adam Grant,
who's also great. You should interview
Adam Grant too. I think I should just be,
you know me. You Must Know Adam, right?
We've treated email before. I need to,
but um,
you should read that book because I think
it might be very useful for you. Great.
No, I'll, I'll take a look at it.
And uh, yeah, I actually went,
was that a group dinner
with her? Uh, you know,
then husband just a few months
before everything happened.
You just never know. I
mean, what if it's right?
I always think,
wouldn't it be cool if people had a
crystal ball and they would see what's
coming that that's such a, you
know, it's always such a mystery.
Like what's around the
corner. And, um, you know,
if you could somehow have
a glimpse into the future,
it's just crazy to think
that you course you can.
But sometimes I think about that.
I do have two friends, uh, bleed,
Kevin Kelly's one who's it?
Fascinating, fascinating guy.
We could talk about another
time, uh, as an Amish beard,
spends time with the Amish,
but he's a technology futurist
with an impeccable track record.
Looks at Silicon Valley. He's built his
own house, spends time with the Amish.
Yeah.
It's all because he's fascinated by how
they choose to adopt technology or not.
Oh. And uh, in any case, uh,
he and another friend named Antonio
have excel spreadsheets or clocks that
they'd look at every morning
that based on actuarial tables,
tell them how many years, months, days,
hours and minutes they
have left in their life,
just as a reminder of their
mortality, intense butts, um,
and isn't dense.
So we are at time and
hopefully we can continue
the conversation someday talking to you
and I would love to interview you at
some point.
That would be an incredible honor.
I would love to do that.
And in the meantime people can see you
at work and doing what you do best.
America inside out,
which premieres on national geographic.
Uh, I believe right on
National Geographic Channel,
April 11th at 10:00 PM six park,
a docu series.
So I will link to that in the show notes
as well as to everything that we've
talked about already. Those
of you, I really appreciate
it. Of course, who listen.
And those of you who watched
him.blog/podcast is where
you can find links to
everything on social media at
Katie Couric on all the socials.
Yeah,
I, you know, it's, it's, gosh,
it's such a fulltime job servicing
the social media platforms,
isn't it? It can. It's
also really fun. I mean,
I have to say I'm really,
I really enjoy using Instagram
because it's a way to feel,
I don't know. You do get a sense of
community with Instagram. It has a,
it has the feel of a
friendlier neighborhood to
or just some of the others,
which compared to Twitter,
more like a neighborhood where you
walked on the street whistling and people
just throw potted plants at
your head. Yeah, exactly.
Isn't always how you want to feel.
If you want to have, if you want to,
if you want to be an insomniac.
Yeah.
Check your Twitter feed right
before you go to bed. Oh yeah.
I got out of a very funny
situation where right.
Couldn't sleep one night
and I got on Twitter.
I was using my device way too much.
I did a whole hour on technology
for this series as well.
And uh, suddenly I'm in a
conversation with Chrissy Tiegen,
Valerie Bertinelli and one other person.
Uh,
I want to say Anna Gas Dyer,
we're all talking about not being able
to sleep at like three in the morning.
It was so insane. And I was
like, okay, this is social media.
Who'd a thunk thunk? It, you only
pitting against companies who put
billions of dollars into r and D to, uh,
throw everything scientifically
vetted at your brain to distract.
So you're completely outgunned.
You were out.
I know.
And that's one of my hours.
And that's what I talked to Tristan about.
Yeah.
They manipulate you to keep you addicted
with absolutely no responsibility for
understanding. And should they, I mean,
do you think that tech companies
need to be held accountable for that?
I think tech companies,
uh,
ultimately if they're going to be as all
encompassing as they certainly appear
to be,
uh,
do you have a moral
obligation to think about the,
the intermediate and long
term implications of some
of these technologies,
even if they're just trying to protect
their bottom line. So for instance,
I mean hopefully I'll take
another minute or two,
but if you look at autonomous cars,
all right, so self driving car as well.
3 million jobs, right? So if you, if you,
you can look at the job shifting
that you can also look at,
let's just say the decision making that
will have to be embedded into the code
itself. So if you have a car, let's
say a car gets hit by huge hailstone,
which these things happen,
right, or whatever it might be,
or a ball comes into the street
and throws the car off course,
it has to choose between hitting say
three school children on one side of the
street or 10 uh,
elderly people.
How does it make the decision and
it's going to have to make a game time
decision or are there times when
the car sacrifices the driver?
Is that dependent on your insurance
premium is that there's a really gnarly
moral problems and ethical challenges
that previously were relegated to thought
experiments like the,
you know,
that sort of trolley scenarios and
things like that. So they will,
they will need to have ethicist and so
on to help advise the programmers who are
developing the code so that these
machines can make decisions. So yeah,
they have to think about, it's crazy
though. It sounds like black mirror.
It doesn't, I know the future is here.
It's just not evenly distributed.
William Gibson, thank you for that.
And Katie Couric, thank you so much.
That would be a good billboard.
It would be a good one.
And I would get a Gif dear Mr. Gibson,
a lot of credit for that, but uh,
everybody check it out, American side
out and Katie, hopefully to be continued.
Thank you. So nice meeting
you. Likewise. Thanks.